breaking tonight senators are on break
after voting 51 to 49 not to go forward
with witnesses now we don't know the way
forward from here let's talk about it
with Minnesota Democrat senator
presidential candidate Amy cloture
senator thanks for the time well thanks
Brett it's great to be on again I want
to get you to react first to the witness
vote and what you think's happening
moving forward I I really thought we
should have witnesses and you could see
Mitt Romney has been outspoken about
this for quite a while and I think the
reason is this the truth is going to
come out and people could vote the way
they want on impeachment I get that
people are going to have different
opinions but I really felt that it was
important to have the witnesses because
we've always had witnesses in these
trials and 70 percent of the public want
to see witnesses and I really believe
with the Boulton revelations that have
come out it's not going to be five years
from now that we know what happened in
those rooms it's gonna probably be five
days from now or five weeks from now and
I think it is better to get testimony
under oath and then people can make
decisions we're reporting at this hour
that democratic amendments tonight
include no weekends session Monday
Tuesday comments on the floor and then
Wednesday afternoon a final vote you
okay with that
we have been pushing for witnesses and I
would assume some of the amendments
there's been some discussion since this
went down now on that closed 5149 vote
about what kind of amendments to extend
the timetable to get specific witnesses
to get specific documents so that's
going to be the discussions and I would
like to do whatever we take it takes to
get a fair trail trial for the people of
America and we are just awaiting word on
what we work out here but you don't have
the votes senator so why go through
those processes if you're you know
obviously trying to get to Iowa other
people are as well why go through that
if you know you don't have the votes
that just can't be my motivating force
right I've got a bet that the people in
Iowa understand
I'm doing my job I'm in the arena you
know other people can say I don't want
to look at what's going on there
I've got to do my job and get to the
truth all right I want to watch I was
reading this quote from Jonathan Turley
who's been quoted by the house managers
the Democrats he says this is why I told
the Judiciary Committee that it was a
monumental mistake to rush the
impeachment vote on an incomplete record
and hand over their case to the other
house as the opposing and the opposing
party this will go down as a blunder of
historic measure by the house leadership
your reaction to that yeah I just don't
agree because we've already seen in the
Don magan court case that the keep
appealing the White House about not
producing these witnesses and they know
very well that they can put all the
president's men even a few of them up to
testify just like they've done in past
impeachment hearings so I don't I don't
buy that
I think they just don't want those
witnesses to come forward and again
eventually the truth is going to come
out and well the other thing I'd say
about it is every day that goes by you
now have general Kelly president Trump's
former chief of staff saying the job is
half done that there should be witnesses
you have a number of other people
including of course mr. Bolton and John
Warner the former senator from Virginia
who have come forward these are
Republicans and said that you should
have a thorough trial with witnesses so
I just view it as a consistent effort to
stop these witnesses from testifying
let's talk about Iowa how much do people
when you're on the ground ask you about
impeachment they do some especially when
things are going on like this hearing
but a lot of them are still focused on
health care and on prescription drugs on
cost of college but I do think this
election especially for moderate
Republicans and independents is more
than just an economic check I tell them
all the time especially people showing
up at my events that may have voted for
the President or may have stayed home I
told them look you may not agree with
everything that's said on the debate
stage I don't agree with everything on
the debate stage but this election is
going to be a decency
check and a patriotism check and they
many of them believe that we should have
a present that isn't putting his private
interests in front of the interests of
this country and that's why they're
showing up at my events are you better
positioned against Donald Trump than Joe
Biden do you think this impeachment
hearing has hurt Joe Biden and his
ability to go head-to-head with Donald
Trump I'm gonna let the pundits decide
all of that I have a lot of respect for
the vice president but I know this about
me and that is that I am someone that's
from the Midwest it's not flyover
country to me I'm one of two candidates
left that are from the Midwest I'm also
someone in another generation and I'm
somewhere in between the age of Mayor
Pete and the vice president I would say
that 59 my age is the new 38 and I think
all of that's a good thing to have a
fresh face to have someone that's new
representing our party at the top of the
ticket there's a one poll out just out
that has you now in third in Iowa the
average of polls nationally in Iowa and
New Hampshire has you you know in fourth
fifth in Iowa New Hampshire where do you
see it on the ground and where do you
have to finish in Iowa by your count
that's gonna be I think just in with
near the top a group of people were in
the top five in both states right now
and that that's good for me but I'm
doing more than that we've doubled our
staff in both states I just got the
endorsement today of the Iowa City
newspaper as well as the seacoast in New
Hampshire adding to the union leader in
New Hampshire as well as the Keene paper
and the Quad Cities New York Times all
of them make that case for me that I'm
someone that can bring our party
together and bring people with me and I
think that's very very important and
I've just got to believe despite the
fact that three days before the Iowa
caucus I never thought I'd be here in
the Capitol I thought I'd be out with my
competitors doing my job I just don't
think that people are gonna hold that
against me I think my experience passing
over a hundred bills by working across
the aisle more than
one in the Senate running for president
I think that's going to matter I just
have a minute left you mentioned the
debates there was a ruling by the DNC
that seems to open the door to Mike
Bloomberg qualifying for at least one
debate coming up are you okay with that
yes I think that when you have got
someone that is running all those ads
all over the place including a Super
Bowl ad I think that it is better to
have that person debating in the case of
Mayor Bloomberg than outside just
spending a ton of money because I want
to make the case to America that I'd be
the best one to lead the ticket and I'd
rather debate him than have him outdo me
on the airwaves and what happens if
Bernie Sanders wins Iowa goes on to win
New Hampshire what happens to the party
I would say that this is a long long
primary and there are many steps along
the way I continue to believe that is
best to have someone leading our ticket
that for instance in my case I don't
support Medicare for all
I read the bill I never got on it I'm
not gonna kick 149 million Americans off
their current health insurance which is
what that bill says on page eight I
believe with education I know that free
college for all sounds good on a bumper
sticker but I think the best thing is to
match our education system with our
economy and when you do that you see we
have over a million openings forecast
for home health care workers over a
hundred thousand openings for
electricians we're not going to have a
shortage of Sports Marketing degrees
we're gonna have a shortage of plumbers
so this means investment in K through 12
one in two-year degrees and then
doubling the programs for college
students I think those are plans and not
pipe drinked they're progressive but
they are practical the center Klobuchar
we appreciate your time I'm heading to
Iowa tomorrow we'll see them when you
get there we'll see if I'm there you
maybe be there but I plan on being there
at least by Sunday okay senator thanks
thank you